what we might be doing when we form
opposite sex friends is basically
recruiting kind of like backup mates the
preferences that we espouse for our
opposite sex friends look pretty similar
to our preferences for mates and so it
suggests we might be cultivating backup
mates and there are some data that
people do this explicitly they'll report
being distressed if their backup mate
forms a relationship
among over 11 600 U.S employees women
were less satisfied with their jobs when
they're reported to a female boss
whereas men showed no difference in job
satisfaction based on their supervisor's
gender
why do you think that is
so I think this goes back to the
challenges faced by our female ancestors
throughout human history a larger
percentage of social groups were Patra
local meaning that when women were
married they left their families to go
live with their husbands and so this
would have been particularly challenging
for ancestral women because they were
surrounded by individuals with whom they
weren't genetically related and we know
that it's harder to form Cooperative
relationships with non-kin compared to
Kin and so I've thought about okay well
how might women have navigated these
relationships how might they have
recruited allies in these contexts and
Dave Geary has made the argument that
one way women might have formed
Cooperative Bonds in these contexts is
through either reciprocal altruism or
mutualism so meaning they're forming
relationships based on shared goals or
exchanging benefits in a tit-for-tat
manner and so if you look at what are
the contexts that allow those types of
relationships to succeed it tends to be
when relationship Partners have
symmetrical levels of power and
resources and so I think one way to
think about this might be what would it
look like if say there was a huge
asymmetry in resources between partners
so say a famous celebrity tried to form
a Cooperative relationship with an
unhoused person or a homeless person
this would be very challenging because
they it would be quite unlikely that
they'd have mutually aligned goals and
over time you would expect that this
relationship would devolve into either
um
kind of exploitation or just kind of you
know a unilateral extraction of
resources so leeching on another
person's resources and indeed that's
what mathematicals find is that when
Partners diverge in power and resources
The Cooperative bonds kind of
um they're no longer mutually beneficial
it's one partner taking advantage of the
other partner and so if these are the
conditions that uphold reciprocal
altruism what I suspect is that women
throughout human history upheld their
reciprocal bonds with unrelated same-sex
women under such conditions such that
they preferred contacts where they were
of equal power and equal resources and
too strong of deviations would have led
to conflict and kind of corroded the
relationship and so I think that this
can become problematic in modern context
where there are clear demarcations in
status and resources or in contact say
where we have social media and we could
observe the lives of people who deviate
strongly from us and their social
conditions that basically these
deviations might be more corrosive to
women's same-sex relationships if
throughout human history our female
ancestors were forming Cooperative bonds
with one another under conditions of
symmetry why is that not the same case
for men
so great question throughout human
history our male ancestors were more
often involved in coalitionary contexts
so they were forming larger groups both
for the context of hunting but also I
think more consequentially for the
context of warfare and so when you form
these large groups
um there tends to be especially in
Warfare there's an advantage to having
larger numbers so a numerical Advantage
so having more men kind of on your team
is advantageous and so in these contexts
what helps is a strong hierarchy this is
really useful for organizing large
groups and it's really helpful for kind
of a chain of command to organize and
attack so if every man out on the
battlefield is kind of going with his
own whims that is really uncoordinated
so if we think of a modern context of
warfare I think the one example might be
football kind of an analog there is a
clear line of command in which there's
the coach and then maybe the quarterback
reads the plays and everyone knows what
the game plan is and that leads to
success on the field so too is the case
in Warfare where you need a strong chain
of command to organize the attack and so
you also need Beyond just a chain of
command you also need specialization so
not every man is going to be equally
talented in every role so maybe there's
one guy who's great at throwing the
spears one guy who's great at making the
spears one guy who's great at kind of
coming up with the strategy and so
having these this role specialization is
really useful for large groups because
then you can maximize your talent and so
if men throughout human history were
more often in competing in these group
based contexts then they stood to gain
from asymmetries and power insofar as
that meant their group was going to be
more organized and cohesive and
successful on the battlefield and so I
think this group component is really
important because what that meant is
that for our male ancestors if they were
successful they all lived and the
genetic data suggests they reproduced
with the local women which is not you
know Pleasant to think about but that's
what the evidence suggests and so there
are reproductive benefits but also just
survival and then for the men who lost
it wasn't just losing a football match
it was death you got slaughtered
potentially the people back home got
slaughtered so there was a lot on the
line and so what that meant is men stood
to gain if there were asymmetries in
power that led to success on the
battlefield likewise they stood to gain
by having same-sex peers on their team
who may have been more talented and who
may have been rewarded with status so if
you were on a football team and your
quarterback is phenomenal and he gets
more status than you do you might still
be happy because your team wins as a
whole even if he is relatively better
off there's a trickle-down effect of his
his ability to help you and because men
it seems were more coalitional that
benefits everybody overall in terms of
Bible and reproduction whereas with
women it seems like they didn't need
this coalitional thing so much you would
have had women presumably competing some
a little bit of polygyny perhaps going
on so you'd have had co-wives of one
particular person you would have had all
of the concerns you have around child
rearing Joyce beninson was on the show a
little while ago and obviously she's
done that great work to do with uh
tennis but she's studying tennis players
at the moment have you seen this most
recent stuff so she's moved on from
female sports teams and she's now
obsessing over tennis players and she's
looking at what happens after a match
between male male and female female
tennis players the amount of physical
contact that they have the sort of body
language the kind of words that they use
presumably to describe how the match
went and you'll be familiar with the
work that she's done but for the people
that aren't
um it seems like in sports teams
men who compete against other male teams
that compete against other male teams
show both more cohesion within the
competition itself amongst their own
team and then once the game's over
they're more happy to be uh physically
and sort of verbally
um collaborative and and complementary
with the uh opponents females during
sports games seem to show both more
disdain for their own side and for the
other side as well like they're just not
really friends with anybody at all and I
think
female intersexual competition for me
has been such a like an obsessively
interesting topic it's so much more
female competition and friendships is
way more interesting than male
competition and friendships I think uh
it's just there's more nuanced and
there's a lot more going on
I'm very very glad that I'm not female
like trying to navigate the world of
female friendships to me seems
unbelievably difficult is that right to
say is it right to say that female
friendships are more complex than male
friendships do you think
I think so um I've become increasingly
interested in how women form Cooperative
relationships because I just for so long
focused on the competitive aspect of it
and the Cooperative part I also find
very interesting because it's they're
intertwined so
as you're saying you know tying into
Joyce bennetson's work yeah she's found
that Co-op competition tends to corrode
female relationships more than men's
like men can more easily return to
cooperation following competition than
can women she finds it in little kids
um she finds it in adult athletes where
that's an explicit goal of the activity
um but yeah there's other work showing
that yeah um in for female relationships
they tend to dissolve if there's more
competition in it and male relationships
aren't as corroded by it and in fact I
think if anything it seems like there
can be a positive aspect to competing
with your male friends and so yeah
there's just so much more overt
interactions happening in male same-sex
relationships whereas for women's it
seems to be a lot more kind of under the
surface things all these dynamics that
are happening that aren't explicitly
acknowledged and so
I've started to look at you know what
are the conditions under which women
form friendships and it seems that the
some of the transgressions that they
would most get upset about that would
most compromise their same-sex
friendships are perceiving another woman
as unkind or perceiving her as not
personally committed to to you and so I
think that this makes sense if we think
about our female ancestors if they were
in these Patra local contexts they were
surrounded by unrelated women they had
to figure out who they could trust and
one cue is just someone who's kind on
average that's someone who's going to be
a generous and forgiving exchange
partner so if you mess up they won't
hold it against you I was going to say
what what's kind mean
kind meaning
um altruistic pro-social generous
supportive
um yeah kind in that sense nice
um and the ethnographic data support it
too so if you look at um what they've
looked at with female adolescents
basically in order to be popular as a
female you have to be super nice
otherwise other girls will hate you they
won't let you be popular they'll really
resent you and envy you so you have to
display at least what that's what they
find in these ethnographies among female
adolescents you have to displace strong
cues of niceness and indeed that's the
trait that women report as most
important in a friend
um men value it too but just not to the
same degree and then the other thing
that we find is that women tend to get
upset if their friends aren't personally
loyal to them so we used examples we
tested this by looking at what
transgressions would upset them and it
was things like you know forgetting it
was your birthday not asking you about
how your family's doing
um never being the first to reach out to
you you always have to reach out to them
and so I think this also makes sense
because if we think about our female
ancestors trying to figure out who they
can trust well whoever is giving off
cues of personal commitment and loyalty
and devotion is going to be someone you
can more confidently trust and our
female ancestors had a lot at stake
because of another woman
became disloyal to them that could mean
a reputational attack and it could be
something like spreading a rumor that
you're cheating on your husband and if
your husband believes it that could mean
your death or he abandons you and you no
longer have access to his resources and
support nor do your children so there's
a lot on the line in terms of
reputational loyalty but also if women
were
helping out with one another's
um provisioning to Children than if
another female really disliked you that
could lead to harm to your child maybe
in the form of negligence or spiteful
harm now I'm not sure how often that
happened so there is some evidence among
the dogon people in Mali that at least
among co-wives there were a lot of
rumors that they were poisoning one
another's children and so what this
meant is like innerport interpersonal
loyalty was a really big deal for our
female ancestors
and perhaps not to the same degree as
our male ancestor so our male ancestors
I suspect would have cared more about
whether the man was loyal to the group
because that predicted the group's
success whereas if he you know was your
best friend that's not as important
what's important is that he doesn't
defect or commit treason and so there's
an asymmetry here and kind of the
importance of interpersonal loyalty
Joyce also taught me about this sort of
um veneer egalitarianism that happens
among women and the reason for that
being that any one girl that uh kind of
seems to be rising up too much above
everybody else is treated pretty poorly
and that resonates exactly with what you
said there in order to be the most
popular girl in school you have to over
deliver on niceness because
popularity and not niceness are
negatively correlated like if you were
someone that wasn't nice you're
immediately going to be pulled back down
right and it makes sense that women
would care about niceness and kind of
popularity and Status driving because
you could imagine that if there were if
you were trying to form a relationship
with a woman who was very status driving
or very competitive she might feel that
she's entitled to more resources than
you or she might abandon you for another
female friend who's going to benefit her
more strongly and so there were
potential potential risks to forming
Cooperative relationships with women who
were really status driving and
competitive and so it would make sense
that in these modern contexts we see
kind of disdain for those patterns
there's some evidence
uh I believe it's Redmond's study that
found that women preferred another woman
who was self-effacing rather than
self-promoting and I think you see a lot
of this
these patterns in women's same-sex
relationships where I've noticed this
anecdotally that you can't you cannot
brag and if you
um receive a compliment you have to kind
of undermine it so someone if someone
compliments your hair you need to be
like oh my God no I haven't washed it in
days it's so oily I can't like oh my God
no you have to like almost like
undermine the compliment um they poke
fun at this and the movie Mean Girls
which I think just got female
interactions pretty spot on
um but there are data to support this so
women tend to engage in this pattern of
co-rumination in their friendships where
they tend to get into these
conversations where it's kind of
rehashing problems
um it's really focusing on
vulnerabilities and your setbacks you're
re-analyzing you know why did my
boyfriend break up with me or you know
why was why does she not like me so it's
just like this really negative
problem-focused discussion in and so you
tend to see this more often in women's
relationships and I think it makes sense
because it's the exact opposite of
bragging instead of focusing on all the
things that are going well in your life
which might signal that you're a threat
and you're competitive and you're status
driving you're focusing on everything
that's not going well in your life and
this tends to be associated with
closeness in women and I think that one
reason
women do this is because it signals that
they're not a threat you're focusing on
everything that's going wrong and then a
second reason that I think women do this
is it's basically
by sharing all your vulnerabilities you
are it's an honest display of commitment
because you're giving someone personal
information that they could later use
against you and so by offering that up
you're basically kind of locking
yourself in it increases the risk of
defecting that if we get into a fight
later on you can now use all this dirt
that I told you about myself and so I
suspect that women respond
quite warmly to these types of
disclosures compared to the opposite
where you know it's just telling you
everything that's going well and how
strong and wonderful my relationship is
as an example well I can imagine given
how complex female relationships are
that performative vulnerability could be
something that's used or tactical
vulnerability this is a piece of
information which in the wrong hands oh
no I really hope that someone doesn't
find out about this but in reality you
wouldn't really care and I suppose uh
who is it that did the work about
venting is that
um
it's not Candace Blake is it Jamie krams
Jamie crumbs thank you very much uh so
she did that I also got the thing that
it's made me think about is
um David puts his work where he looked
at the vocal pitch of men when they were
around men who are higher in status or
lower in status than them and if it's a
man who's significantly higher in status
the other man tends to raise his vocal
pitch a little bit and that's the exact
same thing I'm not a threat listen to
how puny my vocal folds are you have
absolutely nothing to worry about from
me please do not smash me into the
ground and then the converse happens and
it happens even more if there is a woman
around if there's a woman present both
men drop their vocal pitch more and more
and more to try and sort of give off
this uh auditory
um aggressive sound I guess this sort of
uh competition they've got going on
talking about things going well and
things going badly you did some research
about men's suffering and people's
responses to it as well what was that
yeah so that was
the theoretical framework was based on
Kirk Gray's work and he has looked at in
the domain of moral psychology he's
looked at moral type casting which is
this tendency to he argues that when we
perceive a moral action we kind of
instinctively classify people as either
the perpetrator or the victim so we have
this dyadic heuristic when we perceive
moral actions and so we took that
framework and we looked at okay might
there be a gender bias and our tendency
to place men and women in the victim and
perpetrator categories and so across a
series of studies what we found was that
we more instinctively classify women as
victims and men as perpetrators and so
Kurt Gray's model argues that when you
classify someone as a perpetrator it
makes it more challenging to see them as
a victim and vice versa so if you
classify someone as a victim it's harder
to see them as a perpetrator and so
these
roles are pretty consequential because
they're associated with sympathy and
blame and so what we found is that
congruent with these this type casting
we found that people more easily blame
men than women and they more easily feel
sympathy for women than men is that both
men and women fail that
yes we did find in some of our studies
we found that women showed the bias to a
stronger degree than did men but we
didn't find that super consistently
um and so I think that this makes sense
from an evolutionary perspective because
if we think about reproduction women set
the upper limit so women contribute they
basically bring more to the reproductive
table they're more valuable
exactly and so if you have a group with
very few women you're not going to have
many babies being produced compared to
if you have a group with a lot of women
you really only need a couple of men to
still produce many babies a couple of
men having an absolutely fantastic time
yeah I'm sure they would be very
delighted until an enemy group comes in
and then they have to having a bad time
yeah yeah so probably wouldn't last long
but exactly so women are more
reproductively valuable so I think it it
makes sense that we might have these
biases to kind of protect women from
harm but this can be really problematic
when we might be less likely to
recognize men suffering so I think when
we think about the distribution of
social outcomes we tend to focus at the
top end of the distribution where we
might recognize like oh women are less
often CEOs less often world leaders this
is certainly true but when you look at
the bottom end of the distribution men
are more often homeless more often
imprisoned more often dropping out of
school they're more likely to die by
Suicide die by drug overdose so men
aren't thriving at this side of the
societal distribution and so I think in
this case it can be really problematic
that we don't recognize or less easily
recognize men as victims and have less
sympathy for their suffering you see
this reflected in IQ distribution as
well right that you have more men at the
top and more man at the bottom and it's
kind of the same the men are just who is
it that said might have been David bus
that said uh
men are Evolutions play things that you
just you roll the dice with them a
little bit more there's more genetic
variation we'll see what happens they're
kind of more disposable because as you
say it's women that set the upper Bound
in terms of uh procreation
so I understand why it would be the case
that we're more prepared to see men
suffer in one regard that they're just
kind of like less they need to be less
protected and they need to be less
valuable the interesting question I
suppose is in a modern world where women
don't need to be coddled so much anymore
we don't have the same
um physical concerns and yet we have
this mismatch now where the ability to
give sympathy to Men Who perhaps very
much need it isn't there
yeah it is problematic in a modern
environment and I mean for both
for multiple reasons so not only that we
can't recognize men's suffering but also
that we if we're more inclined to see
women in this like patient role this
like suffering victim role it makes us
it harder for us to see them as agentic
and so I think this might contribute to
why we more easily recognize men as
leaders and so it's not always you know
unilaterally positive to see women as
like the patient that's very interesting
yes yeah and so it's like it can be
harmful when you want to you know in the
voting booth you're not going to be
recognized as an agent and maybe not as
a CEO
um but in the context of moral harm
you're not going to be blamed to the
same degree did you see speaking about
the in the voting booth thing Christina
Durante taught me that
in a political race between two women
the woman who loses is the one that has
better marital outcomes long term
like her relationship is the one that
ends up being better long term
for for her relationship yes yeah for
her private relationship I just thought
that was so funny it just everything
gets folded into this I remember seeing
a tweet from you as well about Steve
Stuart Williams study Steve Stewart
Williams found that people respond more
favorably to Scientific findings showing
women outperform men versus the converse
people wrongly assumed men prefer male
favoring findings may suggest gender
biases in reviews slash publishing of
research what do you think's going on
there
yeah so I think that because we tend to
you know see women we want we want women
to to have beneficial beneficial
outcomes we put them in this like let's
help the victim category it can make
them more appealing and and easier to
support compared to men if we if we view
men as perpetrators and agents it's
easier to see what they're doing as
malicious and so if we're kind of
encountering information that women are
have some positive trait we're like oh
good let's help them I suppose as well
what would be the social signal that
would give you
um some reflected glory of championing
the underdog if you're championing the
one that in terms of a cliche archetype
is already the one that used to do this
thing that used to overperform exactly
yeah yeah so you look more beneficial or
you look more pro-social by championing
you know women's success because we
assume women are doing worse across the
board which is true at the top end of
the distribution not at the bottom
um and so yeah I think that that can
that's an interesting it'd be fun to
look at like what moral credits do
people get for you know helping women
they're promoting these things that help
women versus men we did actually conduct
a study we haven't submitted it yet but
it was um it was a politician talking
about men's afflictions in the world and
we didn't say what the politician's
gender was
um so it was them giving a speech
talking about all the ways that men are
suffering in the world and then in the
other condition we just changed men to
women and so in that condition it was
the statements were no longer true and
because it was about women and women are
actually in those contexts doing better
so they're like you know not dropping
out of school to the same degree as men
are and so what we found is that people
liked the politician talking about the
female disadvantages even though their
statements were not true so they liked
that politician more were more likely to
vote for that politician wanted to
donate more perceive them as more
immoral even though the statements
weren't true and so it was interesting
because our male participants identified
correctly identified that the statements
were less true but I don't think our
female participants did and so I think
there support some of that bias that I
was telling you about where our female
participants tended to show more
favoritism towards women across the
board which I think makes sense if we
think about our female ancestors they
needed to recruit female allies so one
way to do that might be to Signal hey
I'm on team women which probably
throughout human history was pretty
consequential because say your you know
male partner was being really violent
towards you you would want a female Ally
that was team women because she might be
more likely they recruit social support
on your behalf but if that occurred
enough throughout human history that
other women preferred the females that
had the female bias then that might
contribute to why we see you know modern
women today showing this pro-female bias
what is it that women want from a same
same-sex friendship I can see what men
want the coalitional you go kill me drag
back type relationship what is it that
women want
so they want someone super nice and very
committed to them some data suggests
they don't want a friend that exceeds
them in attractiveness so they don't
mind if they're you know have these
other admirable attributes but
attractiveness seem to be one where
women are like she doesn't need to be
prettier than I am which makes sense
because then she's more of a mating
rival
um and so yeah what use are these female
friends like what you've got someone who
is caring and loyal and not that hot
um what is it that you want them to do
what are you doing with them
yeah it's a great question so I think
this is actually a more complicated
question in terms of what is the
function of female friends at least
throughout human history a lot of
arguments have been made that female
allies were useful for Aloe care so
helping you care for your children when
I go through the data I have a hard time
finding evidence that it's
non-kin providing aloe care so when I
look at these non-industrialized groups
what I tend to find is that the
um the studies suggest that it's genetic
kin that tend to be caring for women's
Offspring suggesting that it's just that
could be predicted by kin selection and
so in terms of what are non-kin female
allies doing I find it more challenging
honestly to identify what are the
tangible benefits of having these
friends because if you look at Food
provisioning it tends to be men's yields
that are shared more widely throughout
the group what women bring back tends to
be shared more within their families and
so it's not like they're providing
additional food Aid and if they're not
providing aloe care like what are they
doing and so what I suspect a female
Ally is actually doing is
being a kind of coalitional partner in
reputational Warfare and so basically
that she is protecting your reputation
and Hess and Hagen have cool data
showing that women are less likely to
spread negative gossip about a woman if
she has a friend present compared to if
she doesn't so I think having female
allies could protect your reputation
they can also shut down a rumor and say
oh my God no she's not cheating on her
husband or you know whatever and then
they can also help you be a more
effective competitor by spreading your
gossip because if gossip is repeated
multiple times by independent sources
it's more likely to be believed so if
you wanted to take out a rival and you
have you know 10 female friends to
spread the information it's now
distributed much more widely and people
are going to believe it more readily
compared to if you have no female allies
and then there are also sources of
reputational ammo so they can bring you
information question about other
same-sex competitors or opposite sex if
you wanted to you know take out a man
but I think more often women's
conversations are about same-sex peers
so I think that what female allies might
actually be doing is helping women
better compete but in a social
pro-social anti-social reputational
gossip way
physical fights I'm so glad every single
day I'm reminded of being being glad
that I'm a male
um all right what about opposite sex
friends why is it that women would want
non-kin non-partner male
compatriots
the data that I've seen suggests that
what we might be doing when we form
opposite sex friends is basically
recruiting kind of like backup mates and
so
um that basically the preferences that
we espouse for our opposite sex friends
look pretty similar to our preferences
for mates and so it suggests we might be
cultivating you know backup mates and
there are some data that people do this
explicitly and you know they'll report
being distressed if their backup mate
forms a relationship and so
some people do this consciously my guess
is a lot of people might be doing it
non-consciously but still espousing
similar preferences
it's possible also that maybe same or
excuse me opposite sex friends might
have served as protection perhaps if
you're we're really aggressive so we
might also be looking for those
especially if you're Patra local right
because one of the ways that a cost
inflicting mate who is doing more mate
guarding would typically behave is that
they would isolate their partner their
female partner from uh brother's
father's grandfathers Etc and if you've
already been displaced geographically
from wherever it is you're pretty much
on your own and especially when it comes
to physical vulnerability I suppose that
having a male friend around to do that
but it also explains given the fact that
you had to really scrape the bottom of
the barrel to find a reason that isn't
to do with mating for women to have male
friends I think that explains one of the
reasons why men get so uncomfortable
when their partner their female partner
talks about that male friend that
they've got at work and this is what I
learned from David buss's Men Behaving
Badly the failure of cross-sex mind
reading the male over perception and the
female underperception bias of
attraction that you have this situation
where women and men basically exist in
different worlds when it comes to
perceiving what's going on and this
failure of ability to work out to model
the other person's World very much can
cause two people both acting in a true
way acting in a fair and loyal way to
see completely different situations and
to actually have an awful lot of
friction in their relationship
and I mean even just the integration of
male and female spheres is probably
pretty recent you know so probably
throughout much of human history women
were spending a lot of time with other
women and men were spending a lot of
time with other men you see this in
children you know we segregate really
early and so
the concept of working with all these
opposite sex peers is probably pretty a
pretty novel Challenge and so it would
make sense that it would cause a lot of
friction if we haven't you know
encountered it much through human
history that now it's like we just need
to adjust to these new conditions do you
remember when Peterson said on an
interview
we don't know if this experiment of men
and women working together in the
workplace has worked out a notch
remember when he said this it was about
three or four years ago he got slammed
he got absolutely destroyed for it and
maybe it needed more context or caveats
or maybe it's just the fact that he's a
lightning rod for the culture war and
anything that he says kind of gets taken
as like this is the new headline and we
can go after him about like enforced
monogamy or whatever but
um that's a genuinely interesting
question and it also I've been on this
thing for a little while that
the current framing around uh men and
women and their relationships is very
adversarial right it's super adversarial
that men and women are competing with
each other for something I don't know
what it is resources or or positions
within companies or status or victimhood
uh position or whatever it is right
men and women for almost all of history
kind of really didn't give a [__] about
each other men were off with their men
doing their men thing and women are off
with their women doing the woman thing
and they would come together they would
have sex the man would contribute a bit
here and there but for the most part
we're in different worlds and this is
one of the reasons that I've been really
trying to drive home this intersexual
competition point because I think it is
a really lovely antidote to this
adversarial world where men and women
don't have the language or the mental
models to be able to understand how to
compete with each other or why they
should compete with each other and they
feel like they're in different teams but
they kind of really don't have any
ground to be able to do it and it causes
people to concept creep and just
randomly create problems out of nowhere
in an attempt to justify post-hoc
rationalize this reason for some sort of
discontent
but when you realize that almost all
competition between women is with other
women and almost all competition from
men is with other men I know it gives me
a little bit more breathing room and it
also means that I know right okay this
is the rules of the game are better
defined I understand how to compete with
men I don't understand how to compete
with women and I don't feel like I do
and yet I'm being told that I am and
yeah I think the intersexual competition
thing in my opinion is going to be a
very important area of research
um to publicize to like really really
get out there because it's this
beautiful
um calming bomb antidote to kind of the
cultural milieu that we've seen at the
moment I I totally agree and the
argument that now we're portrayed as you
know men and women are portrayed as
antagonistic I think it's true and I I
have some data with some some colleagues
um my colleague Carl Aquino
um and Simon uh and so what we find is
this
when you when people encounter
um sexual harassment policies that are
really strict and so basically these
narratives that sexual harassment is
widespread and the consequences are
really steep so the the risks of an
accusation are very high what we find is
that corrodes opposite sex benevolence
so people are less willing to work with
opposite sex peers they feel less
benevolence towards opposite sex peers
they have less motivation to engage in
romantic and sexual relationships with
them and we even did this study where we
asked them how much do you want to
donate to prevent the suicides of
opposite sex individuals and they
donated less and so what I think is
going on is that we keep talking about
all the ways by which men and women
could have antagonistic Relationships by
focusing so much on sexual sexual
harassment and sexual harassment is a
problem but when we emphasize it we are
creating this stereotype of men as
sexual perpetrators and women as ready
to Levy an allegation at any Behavior
perceived as sexual and so it's creating
this you know the antagonism it's
describing
who's Marina gertzberg do you know her
oh I I think I might have found one of
her papers so this is from my newsletter
a little while ago uh hashtag metoo has
hurt women's careers women's
productivity fell post me too largely
due to fewer collaborations with men a
study of research collaborations
involving Junior female academic
economists showed that they started
fewer new research projects after me too
the decline is driven largely by fewer
collaborations with new male co-authors
at the same institution the drop in
collaborations is concentrated in
universities where the perceived risk of
sexual harassment accusations for men is
high that is when both sexual harassment
policies are more ambiguous exposing men
to a larger variety of claims and the
number of public sexual harassment
incidents is high the results suggest
that metoo is associated with an
increased cost of collaboration that
disadvantaged the career opportunities
of women metoo was important to raise
awareness but the intent was not to
impose costs on women's careers
totally yeah I I think I I found her
paper and I was like oh my God this is
the same exact pattern there are other
data yes showing that people
um are less like so women don't want to
be mentored by a senior male and that
senior males don't want to they're less
willing to Mentor Junior women they're
less willing to hire attractive women
they don't want to hold one-on-one
meetings with women and so
that's isn't that strange that that's
that's men right that's male mentors
do you meant that yeah but so it was
both the ways yeah yeah but the point
being that we're about to get onto it
women also don't like attractive women
if men are fearful now in a post-metu
world of collaborating with women
especially attractive women and women
had a genetic biological predisposition
going back tens of thousands of years of
not liking attractive women
it's a pretty bad situation
yeah yeah yeah it's not great it's so
it's creating the very thing we'd like
to prevent you know that this hyper
focus on everything that could go wrong
is creating less mentorship for women if
we want to enhance women's you know
career advancement then I think we just
we need to have a more nuanced approach
of kind of what are the negative
externalities of focusing so heavily on
these problems which do it's tough
because they do want attention but it's
worth considering how our attention has
also created problems the problem that
you have is there is a current Trend I
think reinforced by the reward of
inflammatory Language online that
overcooking or over egging over
emphasizing any issue that as yet hasn't
been fixed is
uh allowed because we will get there
quicker right if there is one sexual
harassment that is one too many that
means that we need to continue to hammer
the sexual harassment thing and if we
overblow some of the claims or if we
make it more aggressive then it needs to
be that doesn't matter because when you
compare
using words that are slightly more
inflammatory to somebody being sexually
harassed they do indeed Palin's
insignificance the problem is that you
don't get to see these much more below
the surface longer term externalities
that come about by doing this by
overblowing these sorts of topics there
was also another study that you cited
saying a more Cooperative sex in a
meta-analysis of social dilemmas 31 000
people women were more Cooperative in
mixed sex interactions but less
Cooperative in same-sex interactions men
became more Cooperative than women over
repeated interactions what's that
yeah so it was
um a large meta-analysis of economic
games and it was really interesting
because they found that the sex
differences and cooperativeness widened
over iterations so the more games that
you were playing with a partner
you found larger disparities between men
and women's same-sex interactions such
that men became more cooperative and
women became less cooperative and so
what I think is going on there is that
women's
women's cooperation was more Tit for Tat
that if there was one defection it would
lead to defection with women
whereas men if there was one defection
they could maybe recover from it and so
I think this gets back to kind of what
we were talking about with our female
ancestors is that if you want to kind of
sustain a Cooperative relationship
that's through reciprocal altruism then
you're attending to benefits exchanged
and if you're caring a lot about
interpersonal loyalty like who has my
back one defection is a sign that maybe
you can't trust that person and so this
meta-analysis is kind of revealing these
patterns using really large samples that
for women one defection is hard to
recover from again similar to like what
Joyce Bennington is finding with the
athletes like that competition is kind
of corroding the cooperation and so I
think that this this information is
useful because we can think about okay
well maybe then one way to actually help
women and promote cooperation is perhaps
to focus on forgiveness if it's the case
that we are so attuned to whether this
woman is kind whether this woman is
devoted to me then maybe interventions
that focus on forgiveness or like how do
I I focus on for example all the ways
that my friend demonstrated loyal to
loyalty to me instead of focusing on the
one way that she was not loyal to me her
signaled defection so that might be
useful for Designing interventions to
promote female cooperation because yeah
these data are suggesting that all it
takes is you know one defection or maybe
one or two defections and then it
derails the cooperation you mentioned
about how
same-sex friendships for women are kind
of
um Troopers within this reputational
Army almost
um gossip is kind of the the bullets
that get fired or it's the weapon of
choice I suppose what's the what's the
use of gossip
so gossip
one reason that it's advantageous is
that it's not physical attack so the
reason that women don't engage in
physical aggression is because
throughout human history these are Ann
Campbell's arguments women were more
often caregiving for dependent Offspring
and so what that meant is that if you
die your child is more likely to die and
indeed across cultures and throughout
history children are more likely to die
if their mother is not around compared
if their father's not around and so when
women risk physical violence when they
risk injury or death they are risking
those things for their children as well
and so Ann Campbell has argued that's
why women do not use physical aggression
and so gossip is indirect and one of the
reasons it's great is because you can
deny culpability you can spread this
information without it necessarily being
clear that you were the one that spread
it
um and that's important to prevent
retaliation either in the form of
physical violence or reputational
violence you know so if someone then
spreads a rumor about you you're worse
off and data suggests that gossip is
useful because it lowers people's social
appeal and so if we were competing for
mates and someone sped a rumor that you
know I've already cheated on my last
partner or
um you know I'm undesirable for whatever
reason maybe I'm mean and if that
changes a potential mate's decision that
could be the difference between my
pairing with someone who could provide
for my children and someone who can't
you know so it's really consequential
and if people are affected by social
information then that's going to be
consequential it seems like women's
well-being is a lot more on a knife edge
than Menses both reputationally and
physically as well I know that they've
got
um a lower threshold for pain they've
got a lower threshold for infection and
other sorts of things like just
generally physically are more wired to
be vulnerable and emotionally presumably
the same as well
to be sensitized to these threats so the
argument this is an extension of Ann
Campbell's kind of staying alive theory
is that if women needed to stay alive to
provide for their children in a way that
men maybe didn't then they're one way to
stay alive is to be very sensitive to
threats both physical and social so
women are more responsive to cues in
their body so they're more interceptive
or sensitive to enteroceptive cues they
have more nightmares they have more
fears they have more phobias and part of
that makes sense because you're
basically just Vigilant to any threat
that could harm your well-being
um but yes as you're saying you know the
social vulnerability that is
particularly strong because so one
another aspect of why women are so
vulnerable is one huge component of
their mate value is their sexual history
so across human history and across
cultures men tend to show a preference
for sexual chastity at least in their
long-term partners and so what's tough
about sexual Chastity is it's a negative
state so you can never prove it you
can't prove that you're a virgin so if
someone were or that you're sexually
restrained if someone were to call you
promiscuous there's really nothing you
can do to counteract it look at all of
this sex that I'm not having exactly and
so it's a it's really easy to kind of
undermines someone's reputation in that
domain because there's no way that they
can counteract it whereas for men if you
call them physically weak they could
lift up something strong if you call
them you know
not courageous then they could I don't
know do some feat that demonstrates that
they are courageous so you can't
counteract an accusation of promiscuity
um and that was really consequential to
women's mate value and their potential
to attract a desirable mate and so they
are also incredibly vulnerable in this
way and so if you don't have allies or
if other women dislike you your
reputation could be on the line and that
could jeopardize so steering clear of
accusations of sexual indiscretion in
the past
is a Big Driver of all of the different
social setups that women have got that
we've gone through so far
yeah it's a huge contributor because
that is kind of
that's like the Achilles heel in in some
ways of women's reputation like it's
very vulnerable because that affected
make value and your ability to attract a
mate you can call it into question and
you can't undermine those accusations
and so it that was probably and if you
look at the information that women tend
to guard it's really interesting because
women tend to disclose a lot about
themselves
um to their friends but their sexual
history is one kind of piece of
information that they keep close to the
chest they don't share that as willingly
and I've also found that sexual
information tends to pretty strongly
harm women's reputation and their
desirability as friends romantic
Partners
um so other women tend to dislike
promiscuous women
um partially I think they do that for
two reasons one is to Signal how
sexually chaste they are like oh God I
would never do that and then two is to
avoid the woman that could steal your
mate so if you have a reputation of
being sexually promiscuous that's going
to harm your desirability to other women
but also to men at least as a long-term
partner if men are prioritizing sexual
Chastity
um in their long-term mating decisions
does that mean that
women's preparedness to talk about their
sexual history is mediated by the local
sex ratio have you looked at this no
that's interesting wouldn't that be cool
if if you were in an environment where
there was tons of men and women started
to become more open about their sexual
past yeah I mean there are so yeah Dave
Schmidt has data that women become more
unrestricted in their sexuality when
they are in
um actually more female biased India
they need to play by the rules of the
men exactly but there are also data that
when women are when the sex ratio is
more skewed towards women men and women
diverge further in their purity concerns
and so what I think might be going on
there is women might be trying to Signal
their sexual Purity in these contexts
where there's strict competition for men
so maybe there's kind of two routes who
could either go the sexual route and
play by men's rules or you could signal
I am not going to do that you know and
I'm going to be so pure so then at least
I get selected for the long term oh very
interesting yeah well that's a that's a
really fascinating duality of what's
going on because
the the problem that you have with a
woman who's prepared to give it away on
the first or second date is that she is
going to out compete the woman that
wants to make you wait until the third
or the fourth date and that may be able
to capture that man but there is the
Madonna [__] kind of
uh Paradox or whatever it's called where
positioning a woman in one particular
bucket as easy or whatever and I could
you know I know this from my own life
that
the girls that I've got into long-term
relationships with have very rarely been
ones that I've slept with within the
first few dates it's always been the
ones that I've ended up sticking about
for longer now is that because I knew
that it was a longer term investment is
that because of some sort of um
increased closeness when it comes to
make value so you know that they can't
give it up so much and the ones that
have the high make value or the ones
that you're going to get in the
relationship with the longer like there
are a whole bunch of different ways that
it plays about but I totally know what
you mean that you could have this sort
of forking
in a high female skewed sex ratio
ecology you could have a
double-pronged assault but what you
would actually want to have as a woman
is to
um show sexual Chastity publicly no
matter what is happening and because
there is no real advantage to showing
that you are easy and then privately
that's when the different strategy would
come through yeah yeah I like your your
gameplay because it is challenging to
navigate because it's like okay well
there's so much competition and they've
done studies at least in like these
female skewed environments and
universities women feel pressured to
have sex sooner and so there is this
feeling of like well okay everybody else
is doing it you know who's going to be
willing to wait for those four dates or
however long you would normally want to
wait and so women do feel pressured to
have sex sooner than they would
otherwise but then you also get this
pattern of this like Purity concern and
so maybe one strategy would be I'm gonna
signal that I'm you know so high mate
value that I'm not going to have sex but
I think that different women are going
to have different abilities to leverage
that so based on their mate value
yeah so you'd probably would find that
that would be correlated with which
strategy they're going to use if you can
afford to wait longer you should but of
course that's not easy you know that's
not going to be true for everyone yeah
so it's not just going to be your main
value it's going to be your main value
in relation to the man that you are with
so you could imagine a situation in a
High female skewed sex ratio ecology
where a high mate value woman and a
moderate make value man the woman may
play Still by her own sort of slightly
more Chastity rules in order to get more
investment from the man in advance of
and then also kind of bypass that
Madonna Madonna [__] complex thing so
what about
[__] shaming is like if that if the
sexual derogation of Rivals and kind of
the gossip and rules is like the sniper
rifle [__] shaming is kind of like the
dirty bomb that you just throw across
the entire mating Market in an attempt
to raise the supposed price of sex have
you done much research about [__]
shaming
particular threat of the woman that you
are shaming and so my research has found
that women are more likely to share
negative reputational information
particularly about women's you know
sexual history when the other woman is
attractive when she is provocatively
dressed or if she flirts with their
romantic partner so it's more and there
it's more tailored to the particular
mating threat that each woman poses
however I've seen other information
other data that find that women are
more strongly opposed female promiscuity
when they have more male Sons so I
believe this is Candace Blake's work
where it was kind of like support for
female veiling I've gotten on the show
I've got her on the show next week so
I'll ask her about this oh
they more strongly supported
restrictions on female promiscuity when
they had more Sons so basically when
they had more interest in their son's
paternity certainty and so I think that
is one ecological factor is like when
does paternity certainty matter and
that's when you're going to see more
clamping down on female promiscuity so
they've done some work finding that when
women
um in the environment depend more on
men's provisioning that's when you see
more strong more intense condemnation of
women's sexual promiscuity and so you
would predict that over time as we as
women become less and less dependent on
men's resources to survive and care for
their children you're going to see fewer
and fewer restrictions on women's
sexuality
wow so that would suggest
in a world where women are out educating
and out earning men especially at
younger ages
in a world where
women it is popular both uh socially in
terms of how you grandstand and uh to
proselytize around how women are the
victim and they're the ones that need to
be upheld
you could see a situation in which more
loose sexual Norms or less derogation of
loose sexual Norms would be something
that would be
foreign Ed up due to the fact that women
need less resource provisioning from the
men around them
[__] that's cool
yeah and it makes sense that like
Society
would have an interest men themselves
would have an interest in restricting
women's sexuality when they need to be
certain this is my biological child
before I provision resources you're
going to see in those contexts that men
should value women's Chastity because
then they could be more certain and I am
provisioning resources to my genetic
Offspring and then in those cases when
men aren't provisioning those resources
they don't need to be as concerned
Society doesn't need to be as concerned
if children are still surviving and
thriving without men's being confident
and therefore investing these resources
that is cool okay so other than sex what
else do women gossip about
they tend to
share information about women's at least
my research has found that they also
share information about how other women
have treated them and so they share
information about their friends
treatment their friends transgressions
against themselves
um and so this is work that I've done
with Jamie Palmer Hogg and what we argue
is that this strategy is a way to spread
gossip without appearing malicious so if
I were to tell you like oh Mary really
hurt me the other day she made this
comment about how I've gained weight and
that like really hurt my feelings
I sound so much nicer than if I'm like
God Mary's such a [__] she's always
making me feel bad and like saying all
these rude things like I sound mean when
I say it that way but when I frame it as
Mary did this thing that really hurt me
um
then you don't recognize me as a
gossiper and I've shared that same
information that Mary's probably a bit
cruel
but you think very differently of me and
so we studied this and what we found is
that women are pretty sensitive to how
their friends treat them and that this
sensitivity compels repeating those
transgressions to other people and so
they share this information with others
and then when people hear this
information they are less likely to view
women as gossipers and they like them
more when they frame it as a first
person victimization Mary did this to me
compared to we manipulated whether they
said it as a third person statement so
Mary did this to Susan people are better
at recognizing that's gossip but they
don't recognize it if it's your personal
story I think we maybe just have some
belief like oh it's your story to tell
that doesn't count as gossip yet it's
still harming other women's reputation
so what we found is these types of
statements like Mary was mean to Susan
or made this mean comment about her
people disliked the female perpetrators
more than they disliked the male
perpetrators so if a guy's saying like
oh Bob was mean to Steve people don't
get as worked up about Bob being mean to
Steve as they do about Mary being mean
to Susan so when we manipulated the sex
of who's saying these things it was more
consequential for women's reputations
than for men's reputations what's the
bless her heart effect
oh this is kind of another version of
that where I looked at kind of what are
the indirect ways that women spread
information
um and so this was my dissertation and
so this was basically trying to show
that The Way by which women spread
gossip or one way that they spread
gossip is to frame it as pro-social
concern so if I were to tell you like oh
Tammy's been sleeping around a lot and
I'm just I'm really worried she's gonna
get hurt or taken advantage of versus
Tammy's such a [__] you know same thing
where I don't appear mean or cruel if I
frame it I'm just so worried about her
and so I did kind of a similar study
where I manipulated these statements
where I gave people the same factual
information like Tammy has been sleeping
around a lot lately and then at the end
it ended with I'm so worried about her
or what a [__] or there was nothing
there and so what I found is that if you
say it with concern people prefer you as
a social partner relative to who you're
talking about but if you say it meanly
if you say what a [__] people actually
don't like you and if anything they
you've actually harmed your reputation
more than who you're talking about
you've taken the mask off around this
flagrant status removal yeah and so
people see through that when it's that
overt and they don't actually like you
so it's
really malicious gossip carries social
costs and so
that would favor kind of these really
indirect forms of Gossip that we might
not recognize as gossip and the data
suggests people don't recognize it as
readily and so it's basically a way to
harm your same-sex Rivals reputations
without incurring social penalties
who are the most common uh victims or
who are the who which sorts of women are
the most common targets of gossip
so they tend to be tend to be women who
are
attractive
but particularly sexually provocative
those women get targeted the most
um and then other women who are kind of
competitive or really status driving and
agentic they also get targeted by other
women's aggression and so it suggests
that women are kind of taking out anyone
could who could be a threat in The
Mating domain
or anyone who's not a very useful
Cooperative partner not as you know
altruistic that's very interesting the
um
the attractiveness thing is such a
double-edged sword right because we hear
about the halo effect or pretty
privilege and I I it would be almost
impossible to do because what outcomes
is it that you're going to judge for but
it'd be fascinating to work out
what is the optimal amount of good
lookingness that a girl should have
because
if you are better looking than 99 out of
100 other women
all of them are going to have a reason
to have a problem with you I could
imagine a world in which it would be
better to be 90th percentile good
looking because at least there would be
a small number of women above and below
you that you would be able you said most
women want to have friends that are kind
of around about their attractiveness
level at least you would be able to have
a coalition of friends like that whereas
if you're 99 out of 100 who are you
going to be friends with yeah unless I
think the only way you could get away
with like being really attractive is if
you have super low self-esteem and just
talk about how insecure you are like
self-degration yeah that's really nice
yeah overly nice not trying to steal
anyone else's mates but I mean people
have eyes so I don't know how far that
would that would go Michael malice who
you may or may not know is a good friend
of mine and he is a professional troll
on the internet great writer great
podcast a very smart guy he has made a
profession out of winding people up
right online and he once said to me if I
was three inches taller I wouldn't be
able to say half of the things that I
can and he's I think he's maybe like
five six five seven something like that
so he's like a shorter guy and uh yeah
he said and I think that there's
something similar going on there it's
more on the male side obviously but
there's something about
being seen as less of a Potential Threat
especially for men physically right look
at what he said it's not about his
attraction he didn't change his
attraction he changed his Threat Level
his his formidability and um yeah if I
was three inches taller I wouldn't be
able to say half of the [__] that I do
yeah no that's interesting I think I
think one of the domains that's like
most comparable to women's feelings
about their bodies like that is you know
something that we observe women care
about in their mating preferences and
other men derogate one another based on
their height which I just find so mean
and unnecessary but I also just don't I
find male male interactions so
interesting how there's so much
derogation and that's how like they bond
with each other where it's like for
women it's the exact opposite like I
would never make a rude comment about my
same-sex friend's appearance that's like
the last thing you would be you would
have no friends how are you marry you're
looking particularly full today you must
have had lots of gluten last night can
you imagine you know it's the exact
opposite women are like no no no you're
so beautiful what do you what do you
mean no you look great and then men are
just like could you be shorter you know
like just so harsh to each other it's
just like night it feels like night and
day when you observe like within sex
interactions what was that study that
you did about how female competition
changes approaches to diet and
self-image
oh yeah so I've done a few studies
related to that um so one study was
um looking within married couples we
found that when women were the more
excuse me the less attractive partner
um and their husbands were really
attractive they tended to feel worse
about themselves and feel more motivated
to diet
um and exercise so that suggests there
is kind of some relative comparisons we
make within our mateship of like okay
you know how but interestingly it didn't
affect men's motivations to diet and
lose weight now perhaps we would have
found you mean if if the men were of
lower mate value
it or at least we looked at
attractiveness right okay we didn't look
at things like income so maybe you would
find that and we didn't look at drive
for muscularity so that might be where
we would find it where men tend to show
stronger drives for muscularity and
that's like kind of the way their body
dissatisfaction manifests now so that
suggests like this is a domain at least
in The Mating world that women care
about is like being relatively
attractive to retain their established
makeshifts but women also use their
appearance to attract makeshift
um and preserve the ones that they have
and so this other study that I conducted
it looked at the sex ratio of the local
environment and found that when women
perceive there to be more women in the
environment they perceive there to be
more intense mating competition and then
they feel worse about their bodies and
feel more motivated to like diet and
lose weight and so this would make sense
that when there's more you know same-sex
Rivals basically if we're making
relative comparisons then you're falling
farther and farther from the ideal if
there are more and more women around you
the likelihood that you're the most
attractive is now lower and so you have
more women you're competing with yeah
you you're 99 out of 100 but only 990
out of a thousand yeah yeah so there's
there's more intense competition in
women's you know intersexual competition
for mates tends to focus at least in one
domain on their physical attractiveness
and so it led to more body
dissatisfaction and a greater desire to
lose weight and so I think that this
might be consequential if we think of
you know modern University is the sex
ratio is becoming more and more skewed
towards more women
um and so this might not actually be
even though we might be like Yay more
women are getting their degrees you know
we might value it for these other
reasons it might not feel really great
for the women who are on those campuses
to be surrounded desperately dieting
because there's loads of hot women
around them yeah and I think it's it is
worth noting that there's you know we
are designed to make relative
comparisons so throughout human history
we're in relatively small groups like 50
to 200 and so maybe the people that you
were competing with for a mate was just
like a handful maybe a dozen people and
it mattered whether you were the most
attractive or the least attractive it
didn't really matter your absolute level
of attractiveness it mattered how you
compared because that predicted your
um likelihood of you know Landing the
most desirable relatively desirable me
and so because we evolved in these
contacts our brains still make these
relative comparisons even though in
really large populations we probably
shouldn't be doing that as well almost
impossible to be one of the most
attractive people yeah but then if you
if sorry if you globalize the uh sexual
comparison marketplace with Tinder and
Instagram and only fans and Tick Tock
you're basically saying okay now let's
compete with seven billion people right
and so we're like wrongly interpreting
them that is our relevant peer groups
social media is like particularly bad
because they feel like our peers you
know when I'm scrolling through a
magazine I'm not thinking this celebrity
is my peer I don't know for some reason
it's less distressing compared to if I'm
on social media even though I could be
just as removed from This Woman's life
as you know Taylor Swift it's still they
feel like peers and so this might be
particularly bad because we're designed
to make relative comparisons with our
peer group so if we're interpreting them
as peers they might be you know
particularly problematic didn't Candace
do something about sexy selfies as well
in areas of particularly High female sex
ratio split so I believe what she found
with the sexy selfies was that they were
more prevalent in context where there
was greater income inequality oh [__]
yes it was you're right it was
yes [__] what what why is that the case
was that there's more competition for
the few men
some men that have all the resources and
a lot of men who have none that there is
steep competition for the few men at the
top you know you're not going to be very
well served if you're with the men that
don't have access to resources when
they're such high payoffs to being with
the men that have all the resources do
you think that the current mating crisis
sex ratio skew in universities
hypergamy creating this sort of Baseline
of women dating up in a cross and ever
increasing group of high performing
women competing from ever decreasing
group of high-performing men do you
think that that is motivating and
increasingly sexualized culture for
women to step into
yeah it's a good question I I think in
some ways yes but then I also see kind
of also this like backlash culture of
kind of not meeting a man you know so
for these women that are really high
achieving these like female CEOs you
know who are they going to mate with
there's going to be a very limited pool
of men that have more resources than
they do and at least the data suggests
that women who have high access to
resources don't decrease their
preference for resources very much if
anything they just want at all and so it
suggests that they're going to be pretty
Limited in their options but I also
think there's like this like kind of
counterculture of like you know to be
the ultimate woman you don't need a man
full Sigma female mode
yeah so then you might be just like
saying more you know I know some women
who are really successful that are just
going like kind of the sperm donor route
and I've got a couple of friends that
are the same both of them are female
millionaires yeah yeah and to hear about
the process is actually so cool they
have I didn't know that they have this
they have voice clips so you can listen
to voices of the men who donated the
sperm and I do think that that's like
useful information to get a sense it's
really useful than going like that with
a test tube isn't it yeah so I wonder
whether
a genuine polarized counterculture to a
hypersexualized world in which women are
being more sexually promiscuous at least
online you're doing most actually sexy
selfies Etc
I would have said that the opposite of
that would have been like a Trad culture
it would have been conservatism what I
think the boss [__] lean in lifestyle
that you're talking about is is more of
a cope I think that's an inner Citadel
that women are retreating to when
they're struggling to find men I don't
think that that's the opposite and I'm
completely pulling this out of my ass
but I don't think that that's
necessarily the opposite energy of this
over-sexualized world I think that it is
High achieving women outright realizing
[__] I've managed to rise to the top of
my own uh dominance hierarchy or
competence hierarchy I'm looking across
and above and there's no one there uh
I'm I'm not going to let go of the
things that I've got I can't go back so
I'm just going to go on on my own I
think that a true kind of culture would
be something like the Trad conservative
side which is also
what is Trident conservatism well that's
sexual Chastity right that's Purity just
coming up again so it's another sexual
strategy that just happens to appear in
a different way
yeah no it'll be so interesting to see
and maybe it's like kind of like what we
were talking about like maybe you'll
just find this like forking of like two
different strategies you know one's
going the super Chase route one's going
the sexually uninhibited you know men
are you know disposable
or rejecting men all together those are
the three main strategies I think that I
genuinely think that look Tanya you are
absolutely fantastic I very very much
appreciate your time today where should
people go what are you doing next when
are you going to write a book Rob
Henderson wants to know when you're
going to write a book I would love to
um I think it'd be so much fun
um I do want to write a new I want to
write a new Theory paper about women's
strategy to evoke care like if you even
look at Women's
um like their faces they're they're more
neatness like women tend to have like
like larger eyes like they're more their
body structure is literally more like
children
um and so I think it'd be fun to just
write a whole paper on like how women
are designed to evoke care from others
and that's a way by which that they
survived throughout human history there
was a Rutger bregman wrote a book called
humankind and in that he talked about
the puppification of humans and that was
the same thing that evoking of some sort
of uh sense of of care
I love that the puffy vacation yeah yeah
I mean it's not this not the slickest
word in the world uh let's say that
someone's loved what they've heard today
where should they go to check out more
of your work and follow the stuff that
you do
you can find some of my work on Research
gate and then I'm on Twitter as Tanya
Arlene
um but yeah not Super Active on it
because I think it might be bad for
mental health so I'm trying to be
productive instead I like it Tanya I
appreciate the hell out of you thank you
so much thank you this is fun what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]